so last week we talked about president
joe biden's declining approval rating
and it's been a significant decline as
of last week joe biden's approval rating
was down about 16
now that's 16
not 16 points from about 55 to 46.
my sense last week was that joe biden's
approval rating would probably continue
down before it might recover depending
on what happens but my sense was we
hadn't yet seen the bottom the reason
that i thought that was that the full
scope of the afghanistan situation
wasn't yet in last week's polling and
what i mean by that is that the polling
we looked at early last week
was taken mostly before the suicide
attack by isis at kabul airport in
afghanistan and in fact i pointed out
last week that joe biden's approval
decline actually started in july before
any of the afghanistan situation got
going but certainly the afghanistan
situation was not helping and that we
would probably see a further decline
indeed in the last week
joe biden's approval has exactly as
expected continued to decline not
dramatically more than last week but the
downward trajectory is clear and he's
now down to just a hair over 45 percent
approval
we care more about the average of polls
than about any individual poll we want
to look at sort of the general direction
but there are now some individual polls
showing joe biden at only 42 percent and
44 approval and there may be even more
of a decline so what what are the
important notes here why is this
happening what are we looking for what
do we expect
two of the major drags on joe biden's
approval right now are coveted
resurgence with delta
for which really republican governors
and anti-vas anti-vaxxers and
anti-massacres are to blame more than
joe biden's policy biden's policy has
been get people vaccinated keep school
safe but i don't deny that ultimately
the buck stops with biden and he has
said that so that's one drag which at a
sort of nitty-gritty level is actually
the fault of mostly republicans the
second drag is afghanistan
so if kovid improves by november of 2022
for the midterms
i believe people will have forgotten
about afghanistan in general foreign
policy impacts voting less than domestic
policy and biden himself is not actually
on the ballot you can see november of 22
as a sort of referendum on joe biden for
sure but this may not really be the end
of the world for joe biden and democrats
in november of 22. now for comparison to
prior presidents joe biden's approval
today
is still seven points higher than
trump's at this point in their
presidencies
but below both where barack obama was at
this point in his presidency
and below where george w bush's approval
was
at this point in his presidency
so what does it mean what's next really
there's no change from what we outlined
last week on afghanistan execution aside
joe biden got us out of a war that we
needed to get out of that's good that's
the big story the big story is
bush got us into afghanistan
um
obama didn't get us out
trump didn't get us out
biden got us out were there execution
mistakes of course and we've talked
about it there's no doubt about that but
i don't believe that the big narrative
which is biden got us out
and it didn't go perfectly is going to
impact 2022
the tough part comes where biden now
really needs a big success
but the lower his approval rating the
less likely that republicans are going
to be incentivized to work with him
unless he makes some gigantic
compromises for example
on infrastructure which might turn
biden's victory into a pyrrhic one a
pyrrhic victory one in which you sustain
so much damage in getting the victory
that in practice it's a question as to
whether really it's a victory so it's
this vicious circle biden needs a big
accomplishment to buoy his approval
rating but having a lower lower approval
rating reduces the pressure on
republicans to actually work with joe
biden because his approval rating is
already lower and the expectations from
the american public that republicans
work with him may also be diminished joe
biden is expected to address the nation
tomorrow thursday about covid
there's a question as to whether he will
be announcing new guidelines new
restrictions mandates whatever the case
may be
we will see what kind of an audience
that gets we will see if it does
anything for his approval and i don't
know what time that is tomorrow but my
intention is to cover it live on youtube
twitch and facebook so i hope you will
join me it's been already kind of
previewed by the biden administration
that there is not going to be an
announcement of a federal vaccine
mandate tomorrow um
there was some
theorizing and theorizing is even
probably too generous a term there was
some
speculation by some on the right that
tomorrow is the day that biden announces
a vaccine mandate and that's it for many
of them what that means i don't know it
sounds violent but okay uh but the
administration has already said uh that
is not that is not the plan in in so
many words that this is not their
wording this is mine but it was made
clear
that joe biden is not announcing a
vaccine mandate tomorrow but he will be
announcing something and we'll see what
that does and will continue to track his
approval rating
one of our sponsors is privacy.com
they're giving you five dollars when you
sign up for their completely free
service at privacy.com
pacman i've been using privacy for a
little over a year now you've heard me
talk about it before it's a lifesaver
and here's how it works takes just a
couple of minutes to set up anytime you
buy something online or on the phone
instead of actually using your real
credit card number the privacy app and
the browser plugin
let you give each company a randomized
virtual credit card number that you
create out of thin air it'll even
autofill the card number with one click
and the payment is taken out of your
checking account without the merchant
ever knowing your real information so
this allows you to keep your banking
information secure but also to take
control of your finances you can create
up to 12 of these virtual credit cards a
month you can set spending limits you
can freeze them you can delete them
anytime you want so when you do this it
means you're not going to be charged
when you don't want to be because you
can destroy the virtual card number
right after using it which for instance
i love using free trials because i know
i won't be charged when the trial is
over if i use a virtual credit card
number you're keeping your identity
private
by not telling companies who you are
you're keeping your bank or credit card
info protected against data breaches and
identity theft and it's free and like i
said you'll get five dollars to spend
when you sign up at privacy.com slash
pacman